2.8 million people waiting to
find out their future determined not to
be an experiment
the mayor of this region holding the
line i'm not going to be pressurized
into it
and i'm not just going to sort of you
know kind of roll over at the site of a
site of a check this is about properly
supporting those people
whose lives will be damaged by tier
three
pub owners like tim nervous as it
emerges that greater manchester
could be next but by no means the last
place to enter the highest level of
restrictions within the next few days
do you really believe any politician
that promises you
a sharp lockdown would have an end date
if they said today
three weeks and that's it would you
really believe them
i would be hopeful do i believe it no
we're only going from day to day at the
moment because we don't even know if
we're open tomorrow
for the simple reason is it could be
announced this evening
so we live in hope after local leaders
had a bruising meeting with downing
street mid-afternoon
everyone hoping for clarity from this
man here in the uk
deaths have tragically doubled in the
last 12 days
the situation remains perilous in
greater manchester i would merely
point out that over uh the
over the past week the rate of infection
amongst those who are aged over 60 which
is the group that is most likely to end
up in hospital
has risen from 171 per 100 000 to 283
so it is absolutely vital from a public
health perspective
that we act conservative colleagues in
the region
have sympathy with the government in
westminster i think the behaviour of
andy burnham
has been quite outrageous i think he's
uh
he's held the government up to blackmail
it's time for andy burnham
to stop playing politics to start
talking to the government
but this man was one of those council
leaders on the call with downing street
and a cabinet minister this afternoon
which started well
but took a turn for the worse over the
weekend it did feel like we were getting
closer to an agreement it felt like
they'd moved
we'd moved slightly because even though
the position of a number of leaders
around the table oh not all
is the national circuit breaker lockdown
proposed by the scientists
and by the the labour party now even
though that's
that's our position we had uh moved and
and
kind of come to terms with the reality
that the government's policy
is regional based lockdowns but we were
determined that if that's the case and
they're determined to pursue that
themselves
then we need to get the financial
package like i say they appear to have
moved over the weekend but
then on the call today in the short
space of around 40 minutes they took
10 steps backwards boris johnson does
not want to do
a circuit breaker now that kierstama is
calling for the policy
but many in whitehall expect more and
more places to follow the example of
here in oldham which is likely to go
into tier three the highest level of
restrictions within days
it won't end up being a national
lockdown but there won't be many areas
left not under pretty draconian
restrictions
but will it be enough already emptying
out here in oldham
waiting to find out for certain the
future it will become a familiar feeling
in high streets across the country in
the next few weeks
sam coates sky news